hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast
and I'm just checking
in on
you how are you everybody what's going
on oh my goodness have you been watching
the Boston Bruins I tried to watch them
but I got the kids so I only got through
part of the first period there last
night I don't tell me don't tell me what
happened
um we were 5-0 we 6 and 0 I don't know
but uh I also switched over cuz I
watched both game sevens
congratulations to the New York not New
York sorry the Texas
rages they have never won a [__]
World Series and I'm going to say that
they've been in the league since about
1974 they've gone about 0 for that's a
good [__] question how long have the
Texas Rangers just hey
Siri [__] ease dropping [__] all
right uh
Texas Rangers I'm going to [__] look
up their history here man so they won
they they went they won the first two
games in
Houston right and everybody's like wow
this is going to be a quick series and
then they lost the next three in
Arlington to go back and everybody was
just like there's no [__] way there's
no there's no way that these guys are
going to
[__] you know win two games in
Houston and what do they do they win two
games in Houston all right Texas Rangers
established in 1961 based in
Arlington since 197 were they the
original one of the origin the Senators
yes Texas Rangers 1972 to president but
they were the Washington Senators 1961
to 71 now the interesting thing about
the Washington Senators is uh the first
senator's team or this I think the first
one went to Minnesota and became the
Twins and then they had another the
second Senators
team you know they went back again
thinking that they could sustain a team
there and they couldn't and then they
became the Texas Rangers that is right
so they've been
around basically that franchise has been
around since 1961 so for 62 years 63
seasons whatever you call them the
Washington senator or the Texas Rangers
they have not won Jack squat I'm trying
to think if they I think they've been to
one World
Series maybe let's see what we got here
Al pennet oh no they've won it three
times 2010 and
2011 oh they lost backto back years who
do they was it the Giants they lost
to um and then what do we got here they
won some division titles they got some
wild card they're a wild card team well
there you go all right
um so
anyway I'm watching the
game and the color commentator John
Smoltz all right
who was on one of the greatest pitching
staffs of all time they don't have the
hardware to show it they only got one
World Series out of it like I don't know
how that happened but it definitely was
not the problem of the pitching staff it
was definitely the Run support
because they basically were coming up
there you know John Smoltz Greg Maddox
I'm too old to remember the other two
but any one of
them you know every year was in the
running for a Sai Young if not two out
of the four they were amazing they were
[__] amazing
um I'd say the the Baltimore Orioles
pitching
staff you know I put him up against any
of those from like the the 60 and 7s
John Smoltz was talking about the
Houston Astros and he said you know
they're a dynasty and I'm thinking
they're a
dynasty what are we what are we doing
here what do you mean they're a dynasty
and then he goes you know he goes their
first championship was
complicated and I'm like what do you
mean it was complicated they had a
camera in the [__] Outfield wall and
they were wearing a
wire they cheated their [__] ass they
were [__] a dirt bag piece of [__]
[__] team that there was nothing
complicated about it it was pretty cut
and dry that they were cheating pieces
of [__] and I don't know why that they
count that and this is the deal
though and I I [__] stand behind this
that when you do some Ticky Tech
misdemeanor cheating that [__] will
never go
away never goes away but when you cheat
at a [__] level that is so bad it
actually makes the league look bad all
right it's swept under the [__]
rug and there's like a gag order and you
don't talk about so Albert Bell no
matter what the [__] he did people are
going to bring up the cork bat right
like that type of [__] the Patriots no
matter what they did oh they let a [__]
hair out of the ball deflate gate spy
gate they'll bring that up for [__]
ever but when you cheat at this [__]
level you know know like what the Astro
that was complicated there was a lot of
layers to it oh was there was there oh
wow like I kind of thought we had all
the answers to the test there you know
and else was complicated was the Lakers
when they played the [__] Sacramento
Kings and there was a mobbed up ref that
fixed the [__] series you never hear
anybody talking about that right that's
just H you know it's just one guy oh so
I'm the py and then that just [__]
ends I I I'm telling you so anyway
evidently
um I've learned two things this year the
the the in sports the Houston Astros
first title was not cheating it it was
complicated and then I also learned that
I as a white man cannot handle the fact
that Dion Sanders is a confident black
man being
successful head coaching the Colorado uh
[__] whatever he's coaching I mean I
it's weird cuz I thought I was a fan I
thought I was excited I thought I had
his poster on on my wall as a kid but
evidently I didn't evidently I I can't
handle
it um evidently every Trump supporter is
standing in a trailer park you know
every evidently every liberal in
Hollywood is uh going to be a different
sex on Monday you know that just you
know evidently every New England
Patriots fan is eating [__] you know
l lster right next to a
lighthouse I'm telling I think like all
of these things just after a while I
don't even think it's like it be just
becomes like lazy
reporting like there's plenty of decent
people that just go to a a a sporting
event in
Philadelphia you know but like that's
not the story of their town so what they
do is they go around and they try to
find the biggest [__] animal and you
can find that anywhere I went to a
Buffalo Bills game I was out there in
the tailgate everybody is not jumping on
tables but that's what they
film kchen like these people are crazy
you know a lot of people you know
they're they're too old to do that
they're just coming there they watched
OJ play um I'm completely off the map
here uh the rails here
um so here's my question for you guys
what do you think constitutes a dynasty
because when I was growing up a dynasty
was you had to win three in a
row or like the Pittsburgh Steelers won
four in and six years went back to back
twice one four and six
years um but they were never really
called a dynasty they were called the
team of the 70s but like the Oakland A's
went in three in a row they were a
dynasty the New York Yankees
9899 2000 was a
Dynasty uh what was the age 72
7374 the the Montreal Canadians was a
dynasty 76 to 79 the the uh Islanders 80
to 84 that was a
dynasty the Celtics or the Lakers would
have had a dynasty in the 80s but they
they were too busy beating on each other
the Lakers had a dynasty they won three
in a row 2000 to 2003 and then I
remember the first time not winning
three in a row the first time I heard it
being called a dynasty and people were
like what the [__] was when the Patriots
won in 2001 Buccaneers won in 2002 and
then we won in 03 and ' 04 and they
called it a dynasty and that was when
the old school people going like well
it's not a dynasty you got to win three
in a row and then it's kind of like well
you know and I think uh part of it's
just
because you know uh the level of par in
the NFL now I think it's I think there's
a reason why nobody's ever won three
Super Bowls in a row um like the level
of parody is [__] insane so oh [__] I
spilled my water I think
um I can go with even I would even say
in baseball just
because players didn't jump around the
magnitude of players Superstars didn't
jump around certainly the way they do it
in the
NBA um baseball football and all of that
type of stuff so I I this is what I
think I think if you win three in five
years that's about as far as I'll
go all right cuz there's people like
three in seven years as a dynasty it
isn't you you might be the most dominant
team of a decade if you win
three like I don't consider the uh the
the San Francisco
Giants didn't they win one every other
year 2010 2012
um a dynasty is just we have the
championship and nobody else does and
we're holding on to it for at least
three [__]
years and you guys are going to forget
the whole rest of league is going to
forget what it feels like um and they'll
all be jealous and all of that type of
[__] I don't know but whatever but that
was really fascinating to me complicated
it's complicated so anyway
um was hanging out with my lovely wife
this morning and everything was going
good and then one little thing just sort
of set me off you know I love what what
women do is when you [__] right as
you're ready to get going they just go
like I I'm not listening to this this
this conversation is over and they just
walk out and they just leave you at the
height of your [__] anger that worked
out really good for me today you know
what I did with it with that [__]
heightened emotion I went out to the
garage like it was 1988 again I put on
ACDC Highway to Hell I lifted weights
for a [__] hour for the whole album
and then I played drums and that's what
I used to do in the late 80s I used to
work in Warehouse all day long I would
come home I would lift weights and then
I would ride my bike and then I would
play
drums and then that was it and then I
would watch a [__] game I was living
at home with my parents that's how
[__] simple my life was and I
actually worked like less than a mile
away from my
house if I could go back then you know
just for a [__] week it'd be like
even unloading the trucks would be like
a vac
vaction that's all I did and then on
Friday and Saturday nights I would get
[__] somebody get me a case of
Budweiser or one of my friends would do
it and we would go out and get
absolutely shitfaced and then just drive
around drunk that was
essentially that was my life and I used
to work out I would I would uh lift
weights to Guns and Roses Appetite for
Destruction for the whole [__] album
then I would get on my drums and then
play to the album evidently I do have a
read this week it's uh all the Old
Reliable it's stamps.com
everybody you know the Holiday Rush
means more mailing shipping for your
business uh but it doesn't have to mean
more stress stamps.com has been helping
businesses Like Yours save time and
money for over 25
years and it can help you get ready for
the holiday ramp up all you need is
stamp stop 's premium rates for all your
postage needs uh your own personal post
office wherever you are with stamps.com
all you need is a computer and a printer
they even send you a free scale so
you'll have everything you need to get
started I always feel like you're
selling drugs when they say you got a
computer a printer you can weigh out
your [__] get it out to the junkies uh
now taking care of orders on the go is
even easier with the stamps.com mobile
app if you need a package pickup you can
easily schedule it through your
stamps.com dashboard and if you sell
products online stamps.com seamlessly
connects with every major Marketplace
and shopping cart what is going on with
my stomach I had a healthy lunch it's
all
[__] jumbling around here uh premium
discount and supplies at your fingertips
running low order shipping and mailing
supplies labels and even printers from
the supply store get a huge carrier
discount up to 84% off all us PS and
United States Postal uh UPS sorry rates
to help your bottom line plus stamps.com
automatically tells you your cheapest
and fastest shipping options your
postage partner for the last 25 years
for 25 years doesn't even seem 25 years
what beginning of the [__] internet
stamps.com has been independent
indispensable sorry indispensable for
over 1 million businesses get access to
the USPS and UPS services you need right
now from your computer anytime day or
night no lines no traffic no waiting get
your business ready for the holiday Rush
get started with the stamps.com with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code Burr for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and enter the
code bur B
R I also rode a bike like how how did I
have all of that [__] energy
maybe I didn't ride it every day I can't
remember I got addicted to ride my
bicycle one year man and I just I rode
that thing [__] everywhere and I
remember one time I just kept expanding
how big the loop was where I was riding
and at one point I went on this bike
ride and I went like three Towns over
and I was going by Walpole State Prison
which they changed to Cedar Junction and
that was the joke that they try to make
try to make it sound like a train
station you know and um
and I always heard about athletes like
hitting a
wall and I had never done that before
and I was riding on that bike and you
know [__] 80s didn't stretch no
fluids and I was about 18 miles into
this bike ride somewhere around around
the 20th mile I just hit a wall and I
was just like how am I going to get home
cuz I was still like 8 miles from home
so I had to pull over a little
convenience store and what what do you
do you you buy some Gatorade which by
the way is banned in a bunch of European
countries because the level of sodium
that's in it Gatorade is the liquid form
of like taking an ice bath as far as
like Overkill you know what I mean like
that's for like if you're like Kellen
Winslow and you're all cramped up and
they're carrying you off the field after
you played a professional sporting event
for three hours Gatorade is good for you
you know what I mean but if you just
like hung over and [__] it's has a d I
guess it has a d dangerous level of
[__] sodium so much so that it's
banned in these countries right You'
never hear that over here cuz all the
politicians uh are too busy insider
trading and making 20 million [__]
dollars that [__]
um but that's because of the liberal
that's because the conservatives no it
isn't it's because of
Corporations
um anyway so I just stopped at this
convenient store Christies I don't know
if they still have those or Cumberland
Farms and I got like a [__] gay atate
and I drank that and I had like a slush
puppy a blue one if I remember to get
some sugar in me and then I sort of came
back and then I just sort of no pun
intended gingerly rode my bike home and
I was like what the what the [__] was
that um and that is the only time in my
life I have ever pushed myself far
enough physically that I actually hit
that wall but it was literally to the
point where my body was just like nope
no get off the bike and I'm like really
and my body was like yes and I could
have kept I guess I could have kept
going there's this thing where you sort
of like push through it but uh I didn't
know how to do that so I had to like
pull over and
uh take a rest and then that that's then
that's that story I for some reason I I
just kind of lost confidence in that
story right towards the ends like did I
just talk like was that story longer
than the actual bike
ride um so anyway oh my God in the
Philadelphia Phillies that was the team
I was sort of I you know I was rooting
for them but there was something about
them they reminded me of the 2004 uh
Boston Red Sox where a bunch of beards
bunch of [__] animals you know and
everybody hated our team you know what I
mean at least the Yankee fans [__]
hated us like what's with the Beards is
it you they [__] hated that they had
beards and stuff it was like what better
than your [__] team your dumbass [__]
sitting there going like oh you're a New
York Yankee so you have to get like a
cop haircut and be clean
shaven that's so stupid I just thought
that was that's like like you know what
that remind me of that was like a Notre
Dame move you know Notre Dame is as
dirty as any other football program out
there and they try to act like they're
not because Jesus loves them the best
like no one's doing steroids no one's
[__] you know getting some recruit a
hooker come on this is this is this is
there millions of dollars at Stakes all
right there's drugs and there's hookers
even with Jesus I mean Jesus got a
hooker right didn't he do
that the [__] was the hooker's name
Marley or something like that I can't
remember um that was like the Yankees
you know we're clean cut and we're clean
shaven and then what am I supposed to
sit there and think that you're decent
people that you're somehow A Cut Above
the Rest of baseball go [__] yourself I
watched you guys in the
70s all right the whole team looked like
they could have been extras on Barney
Miller they all had [__] mustaches
goose gosage
uh uh Catfish Hunter Reggie Jackson
Reggie Jackson had a frow don't act like
you made him like he [__] came in
there and you told Reggie how he was
going to have his
hair Billy Martin had a
mustache you know what's funny is how
much I [__] hated those guys and now
I think back and I love
them I love Chris
shamas Bucky Dent I'll never like and
not because of that the home run which
is now hilarious to me
um it's it's because he's just he was
just a good-looking guy pretty boy Greg
Nettles diving down the [__] line I
remember that whole goddamn team Oscar
gamble was he on that team some of it
Bob lemon oh I know and then they had
like like the the the the the [__] he
had the hero
jaw L
Panella L pel there's a tough [__]
guy do you know when I went to the
Masters uh couple years ago I saw him I
couldn't believe
it I was like Lou and he gave a big wave
looked like he was really
happy
um that [__] guy that's one of those
guys like all the teammate any any any
team he coached they were all like I'd
run through a [__] wall for that guy
it's I have you noticed like like
coaches the way they look is changing
now that it's becoming about analytics
in
numbers used to be like these strong
jawed Barrel chested guys that even when
they were in their 60s you'd look at him
like I'm not [__] with that guy like
even Bill Parcels who you know when he
would beat his most out of shape you
still wouldn't [__] with that
guy right if old bill got his [__]
tuna hands around your neck that was
that was
it that was the Press was afraid of him
Mike
dka
Chuck
[Music]
null John Madden bum Phillips all of
those guys even the guys that were in
shape like like
uh that coach Reeves out there he just
had like he look like a [__]
astronaut all of those guys it's like
I'm not [__] with any of them there
was you know there was some dirt bag
looking guys but generally speaking like
they were
like big dudes now it's just it's like
the math team [__] math team is out
there you know I'm not saying everybody
body's like that but like that coach on
the
Dolphins like if I didn't know he was a
head coach and you said guess what this
guy does I'd be like I don't is he an
engineer is he making a [__] uh I
don't
know some inroads to stem cell research
he just does he does not look like a
football guy and he's down there
crushing
it
um so anyway oh Billy pull-ups Billy did
seven pull-ups today seven Pull-Ups I'm
getting myself back to where I need to
be cuz I got that I have two long-term
bets on the on the books all right I
have uh that when I'm 70 years old I'll
be able to do 10 pull-ups all right and
then the other one I have is that Kyler
Murray at some point is going to have a
weight problem coming into a new season
there's something about him something
about his face I know he's in great
shape but I think he's just in great
shape shape because he's young but when
he gets into his 30s and the metabolism
starts slowing down there's something
about his face I feel like that guy
likes junk
food it's the most
random it's the most random [__] bet
I had one another one I I bet something
about Rex Ryan that was along those
lines I can't
remember so I got 200 bucks on the 10
pull-ups and I got 200 bucks that Kyler
Murray is going to have a weight issue
um which I shouldn't say this out loud
cuz if this ever got to him that would
be give him motivation and then I would
lose the [__] bet but I'm telling
you he has that I'm going to be fat
face um just my prediction anyway I'm
going to be in
Reno Reno Nevada one of my it's one of
my favorite cities in the
world I love that Arch that says the
biggest little town in America
they shot Kingpin there they still have
the uh the pro bowler tour comes through
there bizar guitar and gun
shop
um all of that
stuff
um I'm going up there with Joe bartnik
it's just going to be uh and it's also
just you know it's a one and
done fly up the night before come back
the day after Bing Bang Boom it's all
good um looking forward to that so I
think there's only a might be sold up
but there might be a few tickets left um
I'm start I got to get better about
promoting my dates it's it's something
that I'm supposed to do but I I don't do
it so go see me there and I was doing
some radio and some
media [__] up for I got a gig coming up
in
Atlanta in hotlanta I got New York City
I got a bunch of [__] I got Northfork
Virginia I got Atlanta I got Hollywood
Florida
I I already I got a nice little stocking
stuffer for my
wife so I already have that and then I
know what I want to get my son I know
what I want to get my daughter my son I
already ordered my daughter I got to get
a new bicycle she's outgrown her bicycle
so I got to get her I think like Blue's
her favorite color I'm thinking that's
also that's a good color too so when my
son you know when she moves on for that
I can give the him the bike as I still
do that I do that hand-me-down [__] this
[__] crap where everybody gets their
own stuff no you don't no you don't okay
the oldest gets the new thing and then
the youngest gets to hand me down and it
builds character that's how it was I
mean I never like there was not there
was no shame in hand me downs when I was
growing up I used to sit there looking
at my older brother when he had a cool
shirt like I was happy for him cuz I
knew in two years I was getting it you
you know and then I'd see it on my
younger brother and I would be ah [__]
man I outgrew that shirt I [__] love
that shirt you know so I know what I'm
getting
them like my son plays drums he's he he
like he loves it he's into it my my
daughter plays too but she's more into
like other things so um you know I got a
bunch of drums with my kit so I'm going
to get like a little 20in bass drum it's
[__] adorable then I got two little a
little rack Tom and a little floor tom
and I'm going to have them facing each
other and I'm going to teach him how to
play his first beat and then I'm just
going to leave him alone and see what he
does cuz he he like dances when he plays
like he's rolling his shoulders and
stuff and he'll be just like wailing on
the snare and you know doing accents
with like the [__] Toms and the
symbols and then sometimes he just stops
playing and he's still sort of dancing
with his shoulders and he starts playing
again and I'm like oh my God he already
he already
understands like it's not what you play
sometimes it's like what you you don't
play of course I'm projecting all of
this stuff but like
um and then what I wanted to get
them
together that you
know my wife said no to which is
probably right they're not big enough
yet
um it's sports related I think that's
why she said no do you know that
remember that [__] hockey game that
you played you you stood up and it was
like it's like foosball had those things
but you were playing hockey and had the
big plastic thing over it and it had
like the announcer and all of that you
can buy one of
those and uh and then you can pick the
team so I would of course pick Bruins
and
Canadians
um oh God speaking of
that my daughter you know because we've
been watching like sports and stuff she
was going like so who's the team for
like like you know Massachusetts and I
was saying you know it's a Boston and
Red Sox cuz I was watching baseball and
she goes and and who likes the Yankees I
said that's New York New York
City and then she goes all right she
goes well I'm from Los
Angeles who's their team and I was like
oh God I knew this was going to happen
but she is from Los Angeles so I'm not
going to be a douche and I I don't mind
the Dodgers so I'm like it's the Dodgers
so she's like all right then then that's
my team I go you don't like the Red Sox
she goes no I like the Red Sox first but
I also like the Dodgers I'm like that's
all right
it's just going to kill me if she likes
the
Lakers um but here's another thing too
it's just [__]
Sports you know and that's one of the
advantages of being an old dad if I was
younger that really would have bothered
me and now I'm just like who gives a
[__] it's just a bunch of people putting
a ball through a [__] hoop um what do
I care right you rot if you want to I'll
root who I want to I don't give a [__]
um so anywh who um do I have any advert
I don't think I have any
advertising for this week
right I do not and we're almost at the
end here um got an amazing espresso this
morning from this coffee shop that I
hadn't been to in a while and they they
have the basically the best espresso
within the vicinity of my
house um they're just a little out of
the way but it was definitely definitely
worth the trip and uh you know I got you
know one of those Italian little [__]
coffee makers when I worked out in
Springfield and I saw this video on
Instagram on how you're supposed to use
it it's B if you have one okay you fill
up the strainer you don't want to pack
it with the coffee but you're supposed
to boil the water
first all right and then pour it in
you're supposed to pour hot water in not
room temp temperature water because some
of it as it's heating up is going to go
through your coffee and it won't be at
the right temperature it's really wild
and then when it starts percolating
you're supposed to have the top open cuz
I'm sitting there going like how the
[__] do I know when this shit's done
you're supposed to have the top
open and um I got to watch the video
again there's something if it's if it's
boiling too much when it comes out take
it off the heat because you'll like get
it'll affect the taste of the hockey
hockey the coffee
um so I'm going to actually I'm going to
go give that a try I saved the video I'm
just babbling this week people um I'm
actually in a great mood because of uh
the support you guys gave me on
something that you know because it's a
project that I did but this this strike
thing and I really believe in this
strike and the greed that these people
are showing on the other side is just
[__] it's
disgusting um which I just don't
understand I don't understand why you
want to have all the money I don't I I
I'll be honest with you I just don't
even understand
business I don't get how like why it
can't be like hey you know we both make
money and we're both happy it's just
that's not how it works it's like no I
have to [__] you I gotta [__] you to
make myself feel like I'm winning it's
just
so just a [__] awful way that
business is but it is what it is so
anyway um that is the podcast
enjoy your weekend you [__] and I will
talk to you on
Monday hey what's going on it's Bill
Burr and it's time for the Monday
Morning podcast for Monday October 26
2015 what's going on how are you is
everything good with you did you have a
good weekend Oh God bless you God B
everything good with the family oh God
bless you um I am in uh beautiful
downtown Detroit
Michigan um I know some of you probably
laughed cuz You' hear all that [__]
[__] about Detroit all the time this
[__] city is awesome um it can't be
scary I'm not going to lie to you but
every time I come here it gets a little
bit better and
um you know it's kind of a [__]
exciting thing you know it's one of our
great cities here sits here right by the
lake right Lake Eerie
you
know beautiful goddamn City you know I
like when you go through Detroit is you
you always see a bunch of Cadillacs
Buicks even though those [__] [__]
left this
place I swear to God man you know I
don't know who's at fault for that [__]
if it really is just the corporate greed
or if the unions became just such [__]
that was it was cheaper I always go with
the corporate guys being [__]
because you know basically if you didn't
have the unions we'd have sweat shop
labor in this country right so then they
just went but then the unions became oh
my God the unions have horrible
reputations which is well earned isn't
it oh it always starts out with a good
idea doesn't you know some theaters I go
to a union some aren't and sometimes the
unions are cool and sometimes they're
not you
know [__] guys just sitting there on
a chair
there you know it's like dude why would
you do that just go in the back and play
cards I'm sitting there looking knowing
that I'm [__] paying you you're not
doing
anything I don't know look at me I'm all
over the map right now anyways that's
one of the worst [__] things we ever
did was
uh I don't know we allowed all of that
[__] industry to leave this country
so [__] stupid we should still be
here making those cars right you can
feel good about it you know what I saw
more guys God damn Buick Regals you know
they brought that car back you know and
it looks [__] cool right Buick's
always had cool front grills but you
yeah you know just grossly underpowered
that'd be a great car to [__] uh to
redo just pull the whole [__]
drivetrain out put a new suspension and
it just you know have yourself a [__]
sleeper right keep those granny looking
[__] tires and
rims um
just like that was that movie what was
that movie Ryan gosson was in and he
would pause 30 seconds to deliver his
line he had that that monolisa smile he
always has is it Mona Lisa it's
mozarella rat right I always thought
ricares I guess forgot I'm learning all
this [__] from [__] verie and Joe
bartnik the two half Italians that are
on the [__] bus dude listening to
Italians talking about
food is one of the funniest [__]
things ever but then after about like 15
minutes they it's as annoying as
listening to somebody who's talking
about their kid that you don't give a
[__] about you know what I mean like oh
you can't believe so then Little Joe
Joey came in right and he had his little
slipper song he was so cute and I said
Joey do you know what time it is and he
said it was
14:00 isn't that funny that doesn't
exist you just got to sit there and be
like I don't give a [__] about that
little snot nose kid
right and you got [__] bartnik and
ver bartnik and ver when we were in
Pittsburgh and we played Hines Hall um
they went to some [__] Italian deli
in the morning and came back with all
these cheeses and uh they came back with
this uh was it Capac
capicola AKA gabu which was [__]
unreal I guess it comes from the the
neck of the pig you wouldn't think that
would be any good they came back with
spicy
gabble and
um it was was [__] amazing but they
wouldn't shut up I guess it comes from
the shoulder or the neck I should say
they wouldn't shut up about it they're
going Bill and in the corner they had a
whole section it was just
Jesus they had
provolone
mozarella [__] going on and on okay
and then we're standing there and then
Joe
I I I pull out this piece of bread bill
and I hand it to Joe and he squeezes it
and it he knotted at me dude it was like
a mafia Hitman telling somebody was
going to get whacked right and then you
think it's over and then we go over to
the other then they had all these
olives they had spicy
olives they had olives with garlic in
it and I was like I'm getting the spicy
one and then Joe's like oh I'm getting
the [__]
garlic and then they had all these wine
she's like all right I get it Jesus
Christ [__] get it I see it it's
right here try that try that dude try
that sharp proong go ahead take a piece
of that no no no put it on the bread put
it on the bread pull a little gabble go
on
there I'm [__] around it it's it's
actually hilarious but they just
wouldn't shut up about the place and the
food was unbelievable L delicious
they're [__] great okay but you can
understand I'm German Irish all right we
just put [__] in a pot you boil it and
then you think about either drinking or
uh eliminating a race of people that's
that's that's the family tree that I
come
from all right there's nothing about
food
um it's probably just all jealousy man
the [__] food was Unreal you know
what's funny verie made me a plate we're
on the bus right and he makes me a plate
and I can tell he's got his back to me
and I can tell tell just the way he's
laying it out he's so [__]
excited he wants me to love it as much
as he loves it right so I [__] uh I
he gives to me I start eating and it's
[__] delicious and I didn't realize
he's waiting for me to say it's
delicious cuz I'm so busy eating it cuz
it's delicious and then he just sort of
like just was looking at me he
goes how how is it it is it good and I
just I spit take bursted out [__]
laughing I like yeah dude it's delicious
he was like all right good good like he
was almost like I don't know why do why
do Italians give a [__] that much about
food and every everybody else doesn't
they pretend to nobody gives a
[__] that's why that food is so [__]
unbeliev it's the best food on the
planet you
know [__] I if you start to make a
meal and there's an Italian person in
the [__] room if you start [__] it
up they'll get emotional like oh no what
what are you do no no you you want to
put the [__] what you do you you just
like dude just you just do it you just
get over here you know what I
mean it'd be like if I started playing
drums and a black guy walked in I big
all right dude here's the stick you you
just do it you just I don't know why
you're just
better so anyways I never heard of caola
before you know I heard of
cabbage you know bror and sausages and
all of that [__] [__] you know what's
funny as much as I love Italian food I
would love I'd love some [__] some
German food right now some Kraut some
[__] giant goddamn beerstein dress
like I'm going to walk out of a cuckoo
clock you know what I mean you know
thing about Germany is is we're never
going to shake off that World War II
[__] we're just never going to do it you
know what I mean we went too hard you
know it's over how there's no way
there's certain things that you do
there's no comeback from I don't give a
[__] how good a car you make you know
what I mean I don't give a [__] how good
good your beer is I don't give a [__]
how good the watches you make you know
what I
mean you pick one wrong
guy and he ruins it he just [__] Ru
how [__] long you know what I mean
what about a till of the hunt where was
he
from that's what happened he was from
some [__] I don't know Empire right
where was that guy from was he from
Jersey let me look at this guy but who's
the guy the the [__] guy the Impaler
Vladimir the Impaler where the [__] was
that Maniac from you don't
know or wherever the [__] he's from
doesn't exist anymore so people can move
on Vladimir the impal that's how they
who they based like Dracula
on where is V Vladimir the Impaler here
we
go oh Jesus Christ I got to tell you
something right now this [__] Detroit
Wi-Fi leaves something to be desired you
know what is exciting about [__] yeah
it's not going to come up it's doing
that stupid pin wheel spin it wheel turn
it
around giving me no internet you [__]
[__] trying to read about a douche you
stuck W up your ass we got no all right
Vladimir the Impaler was a member of the
House of dracul some [__] yeah this is
all Do they base track here where where
was he
from what street what country was this
guy from Transylvania Noble
woman that was his
wife house house of Dracula father I
don't give a [__] about his dad where
they
from Bust of Vladimir they have a
[__] bust of this
guy you know what I mean you go to
Germany they don't have a bus to Hitler
do
they
Bust the Move right [__] have a
little hologram of [__] Hitler doing
the running man you know the thing about
it is is every other
[__] you know wherever the [__] they're
from it doesn't exist
anymore look I'm imprisonment and hungry
all right so there's a
country they put that guy in jail they
didn't [__] impale him dude you ever
hear about like imp impaling I'm not
even to go I'll go through it really
quickly they basically split you up your
backside all right grease up a [__]
steak and and basically use your body
weight to have it go in through the
outdoor sometimes it eventually your
body weight it pierces you through your
gut sometimes it would come all the way
up through the person's [__]
mouth take like [__] I don't know 12
hours to days to die that way and he
used to do it all the [__] time he
had like a whole [__] can feel the
people there and he'd be sitting there
eating some gab with the [__] cheese
M um no one knows where he is was he
from Romania you know they were able to
shake it off if you say hey I'm Romania
what do they think they think you're a
gypsy stealing a [__] wallet in
[__] Rome that's that's all they
think you know what I mean you say
you're German do they think about the
beer they think about the cars no so
he's like what are you a Nazi uh no I'm
not I'm a drunk
I don't know how to make a
car anyways I don't know what I'm
talking about here um let's get back to
Detroit so I guess the owner of the
Cavaliers or some [__] I probably should
have got the guy's [__] name he
bought like [__] like like 70
buildings out here he's giving major
companies
breaks
um to come in here I guess Google has
some offices Twitter or something like
that and it's starting to build back up
again now whether he did it for finan
Cal reasons or what it's the most
patriotic thing that's been going on
here in a long [__] time and um
another cool thing was when I went to
Cleveland Cleveland like every time I go
there every two years it looks it's it's
making a major comeback I was joking
when I was on stage they had like
flowers going right down the center of
the road on one of the roads that was
unheard of 10 [__] years ago when I
was out there I told you I used to get
an escort from the [__] I don't me a
who I had like a cop have to walk me
over at the end of the night from the
club over to the hotel to make sure I
wouldn't get jumped and hilarities was
the only uh was the only you know only
show in town right there and now that
whole [__] Street it looks like the
Vegas Strip and um I'm telling you
everybody out there if you're making
some money don't sleep on the so-called
Rust Belt it's coming back you can make
your fortune
there
um you know it' be cool if there was a
way to [__] do it and not displace
the people that already live there you
know if you could somehow buy a [__]
building fix the [__] thing up and
then help out the people that were in it
but it never works out that way does it
there's got to be a way to do it right
if you did it you'd end up on Oprah
right and she'd sing your
name
uh I don't know what I'm talking about
here so we've been rolling through here
um I am on a [__]
all right I every [__] show I go I'm
not drinking
afterwards and
um and then it just happens to me I'm
just I have to break this [__] habit
it's it's every you know what I got into
on this trip I got into light beer from
Miller I was never a Miller like guy I
[__] hated it but they brought back
the old school bottles that they used to
have those short squat ones and when I
was coming back from the Notre Dame game
we had them in this [__] ice chest
and they were so goddamn cold so [__]
[__] delicious it just turned
something on now I'm like craving it
last night I was just like all right
guys I just want to go home and I'm
[__] right outside the Fox Theater by
the way which is one of the top three
theaters I think I've ever played in my
life um I probably say Carnegie
Hall Chicago theater and the Fox Theater
in Detroit oh but the Tabernacle in
Atlanta's cool there's so many cool ones
but this one was um you know we got to
the show a little bit late so I didn't
have time to go out and like look at it
before the crowd came in but when I came
walking out with the lights down it was
reminding me of like Royal Albert Hall
like [__] gigantic it's one of the
biggest places I ever played and uh the
crowd was amazing and afterwards me and
bartnik were hanging out in the lobby
part and exceling the CD and I was
taking some pictures and [__] talking to
the people down there and
um so you know we're all talking about
oh we're going to be good boys we're not
going to go out and blah blah blah blah
blah and then you know I get ver you
look he starts [__]
laughing and next thing you know you
know right around the place they had a
place to get tacos and they had another
place to get [__]
uh drinks and [__] but I was like no no
no man let's get in the car let's just
go back to the [__] hotel all right
they have a little Hotel bar there we'll
get one quick one we'll watch the end of
the Panthers [__] Eagles game we'll
go to bed we'll call it a night so then
we show up we sit down at the bar
there's some guy sitting there and it
looks like he just sat down and a four
toop just left at the bar um and I found
out all of the drinks was were his and
he was a chef and he was trying every
drink that this place had was sampling
them or something this guy Manny so next
thing you know we start doing what he's
doing and uh it was stupid I just
remember verie with you know you don't
mix liquor right and we're doing it just
because we're laughing cuz we know it's
stupid and I remember we drank this
[__] this coffee flavored tequila and
as ver bringing it up to his lips he
goes ah I'm definitely puking tonight
and then he just throws it
down so the weird thing was there was so
many different kinds of Liquors in me
had a Moscow
Mule I had some Patron I had some like
this [__] that coffee flavored
Patron I had one light beer from Miller
then I had this other [__] that had like
an orange in it with bourbon in
it and the funny thing was is I didn't
even feel drunk I'm going to ver like I
think this shit's watered down he goes
yeah it's a good point I don't really
feel drunk either and then I went
upstairs I got on
FaceTime and I got into a big fight with
my wife and I woke up this morning I was
like yeah I guess I was drunk I was just
being mean for no reason and I'm not a
mean drunk I'm a happy drunk but when
you [__] you know cross-pollinating
all of those
things I was I was I wasn't mean I was I
was sirly she was like you have you been
drinking I was like no
it's being an [__] you know what's
funny she's such a sweetheart she hung
up on me and she apologized to me so I
got to wait till she wakes up cuz I'm
still on East Coast time I'm going to
fck I'm going to apologize to her I'm
sorry honey I'm
sorry so
sorry that I drank 50 different kinds of
booze and then I called you and I was a
red
[__] can you ever forgive me lady um hey
just let all you guys know um I have
still have some leftover posters from
that tour that I did up the
Northwest that tour where I got the
inner tube standing in the dry riverbed
that one um they will go on sale
tomorrow morning that's Tuesday
Morning October 27th 2015 cuz God knows
you might be listening to this 5 years
into the
future how's California doing person in
2020 does it still exist all right very
limited Northwest posters less than 50
also there will be 75 Bible Belt posters
available they're all
autographed and um you can get them uh
off of the merch page on Bill bird.com
all right
now what did I want to do here there was
something I was going for oh that's
right I got to read a little bit of
advertising here you know all right okay
here we go we're starting right out of
the
gate um all right how many minutes into
this are we 24 minutes it's 9:54 a.m.
all right this is going to work out good
I got to be on the bus at
[__] 11:00 a.m. and then tonight
we're we're uh in Grand Rapids
Michigan and I got some relatives coming
out to that as I mentioned I got I got
relatives in
Indiana Ohio Michigan I'm from out these
here parts and uh oh so I got my I got
speaking of underwear here trunk Club in
meundies I actually did my laundry or I
had somebody do it for me you
know um I walked like a mile and a half
through downtown Detroit yesterday uh
which is a scary thing for anybody to do
forget about when you look like a sickly
Ron Howard and
[Music]
um I went down and uh found a laundry M
it's like the greatest [__] feeling
when you're on tour is when you get your
laundry done you know what I mean is
it's starting to pile up in your bag you
know and you got it all [__] twisted
up in your your [__] grocery bag you
know and all of a sudden you're looking
and and your your suitcase is getting
all empty looking cuz everything's
[__]
dirty I mean I went over there gave him
every [__] thing that was dirty and
uh I am elated now so that's going to
get me through the rest of the tour but
when I get to Chicago I'm going to get
my on uh my laundry done again cuz I
hate having dirty laundry in my [__]
luggage it's just [__] gross you know
and you just pay somebody else to do it
don't be a cheap [__] all right I went
down there it was minim it was $150 a
pound minimum 10 lb thing and I went
down there with just my [__] meundies
meundies and my [__] socks
right that's all I brought down there
right because they're going to dry
everything on
high you know they're going to dry
everything on high so you can't give
them anything that's going to [__]
shrink so you don't give a [__] about
you under where he suck so I'm just
bringing that [__] down on there I mean
it probably weighed 2 lb and they still
charge me $12.50 to do it and you know
what I don't give a [__] I would have
given him 20 bucks to do to pay another
person to do your
laundry I mean Jesus Christ you're
living like a
king they got it all folded you
know washed my compression socks I wear
compression socks now it's really
helping as I'm getting this [__]
varicose vein treated in my left leg
it's really helping it out the guy told
me to get him it's like dude I'm not
wearing those [__] socks I might as
well get sock gers at that point it's
basically like the Allen Iverson sleeve
that he wore for the last three4 of his
career except it's on your legs um and
it feels weird at first but I got to
admit on a cold day it's kind of nice to
have socks that go up to your
kneecaps but when you put them on and
you're standing in your underwear and
you got them on like last night I had
the old man once like I went to uh I
bought some from Nike that were actually
they're kind of nice but I bought the
old man ones from the [__] like the
right a to the [__] CVS and they just
jet black and they went up to my knees
and I was standing there in my [__]
underwear and I just bursted out
laughing I look like that [__]
50-year-old married white guy that gets
busted you know getting thinks he he's
getting a hooker and it's some
undercover cop and then I just start
crying oh I was I was just trying to
talk to her right being that guy
um by the way I apologize for putting
that image in your head but it was just
too [__] funny not to share it with
you
um so anyway so I went on a nice walk
this morning uh it was a nice mile and a
half walk there and back and then I I
did it again this morning and
um you know it's cool it's cool to be in
Downtown Detroit and there's people
coming to work down here excuse me
hiccups here um people coming down to
work um it's great to see Cleveland
coming back and all those I swear to God
man I got to buy something out here I
think it's a smart move and it's really
uh I think it's a patriotic thing to do
to invest in a [__] city that was the
[__] and and and it should be the [__]
Detroit should be the [__] it really
should Cleveland should be the [__] all
of these [__] places so uh you can
I'm going to be the like I'm going to be
the real estate agent for these these
[__] cities and uh and I won't take a
commission how about that yeah you can
buy something for
nothing you know and you can help this
[__] place come back I mean I don't
know you figure you know you start
buying up buildings and then they
legalize weed right and then somebody
buys the old Packard [__] Factory and
you just start making weed in there
there you go that's the [__] move you
come back to
Detroit and all those you know grandsons
and granddaughters of the great Auto
Workers in this
country right they go back to work in
the same Factory except you're growing
weed
come on man that's like that Michael
Keaton movie from way back in the day
except you got weed in it
right I don't know these are just ideas
I'm just throwing it out there all right
let's talk some sports here let's talk
some sports and we'll start with the
greatest [__] sport that's ever been
created NHL hockey goddamn [__]
[__] Frenchy sons of [__] the
[__] I can't even [__] on them at
this point the goddamn Canadians are 9
and0 9 9
and0 have won 18 out of a possible 18
points and for the longest time nobody
in the East looked like they could [__]
with anybody in the west and uh I don't
know it's looked I mean they well the
best record out in uh out in the west
who do we got Los Angeles is is five and
three after a slow start they're turning
it on Nashville 6 and one Dallas Dallas
is looking good huh
to Winnipeg you know what it is though
the Habs don't have a tough guy I don't
know if that's cuz we got rid of Lich or
whatever from what I heard I was talking
to a Canadians fan last night actually
had I took a picture with them too you
know just like and I actually made his
his girlfriend a wife standing between
us because this dude I can't put my arm
around you with that [__] shirt on um
but he was saying that uh they they
don't have they don't have a tough guy
anymore and um so I don't know I think
that might come back to haunt you If he
if you end up playing whoever the [__]
makes it to the finals out there right
kings are tough Winnipeg's
tough Chicago you never [__] with the
Blackhawks
right I don't know who the [__] knows
but anyways congratulations to those
[__] I mean you got to you got to you
got to give respect to that 9 and0 is
[__] insane but the Bruins hanging on
they're doing all right 3-1 and one
that's a winning record I think the uh
the tie there we [__] blew it against
the filthy flyers then we came back and
we beat the Islanders you know cra's
having a [__] career year think he's
leading the leading points I don't know
I'm psyched and um you know it's going
to be great when I get back even the
games that we lose I don't give a [__]
I'm going to have all these games on my
DVR I'm going to sit down and watch all
of them I get to watch a game a night
you know sometimes two games that the
Bruins have a game and I'm going to get
all [__] caught up um in the NFL
yesterday the Patriots beat the Jets um
I got to tell you man Jets were getting
11 points I loved that [__] I love
that [__] bet the Jets getting 11 um
I was actually thinking that we could
possibly lose to them just because we
had we have no [__] offensive line
and they got a great defense you know
Rivas is going to shut down his whole
[__] part of the field and um what
did we end up winning by we ended up
winning by uh seven points but uh
Edelman dropped that pass then you
always go if you dropped that pass and
it would been yeah but if he caught it
maybe they would have done something
different you never know so uh you know
we beat the Green [__] they're not the
green [__] anymore cuz Rex Ryan isn't
there but uh I got to admit it's I'm
kind of uh this is the German in me what
do they call it shiden Freud is that
what they call it taking pleasure out of
somebody else's suffering seeing the
bills struggling not cuz I don't like
the bills just because Rex Ryan talks
all this [__] about what he's going to
do to the Patriots it's it's kind of fun
to see the Jets be a quality Squad with
the Class Act for a coach you
know and to watch him [__] losing to
Jacksonville all the way over there in
England it's [__] great but there's
something about Rex I still love the guy
I'm feeling bad for he looks like he's
putting on weight again I think he's
stress eating you know talked all that
[__] there's always people talking [__]
there was somebody on the Jets talk [__]
but what they were going to come up and
do to the Patriots it's like why would
you do that why would you give them
extra motivation I hope people continue
to [__] talk [__] you know what I
mean we know you think you're going to
win we know you're going up there to win
and we know you're not scared you just
don't say it you dope yeah we going to
go up there we going to [__] we going is
that what you're going to you're going
to go up there and play
football how about the
Dolphins Jesus Christ talk about making
your former coach look like a [__]
jerk off they came in there and
absolutely raped the [__] Texans you
know what they win like [__] 97
to2 where is it as you can tell I was on
a bus I barely saw anything I watched I
watched the Dallas game and I uh and I
watched uh the Patriots that's all I saw
and I also saw the end of uh the
Panthers it's pissing me off that I keep
missing uh the Panthers play because I
feel like I'm missing uh the emergence
of the next great quarterback in the
league and for the life of me I can't
remember his name he has those Michael
Jordan ears where they're really tiny
but they look like the tops are stapled
to the side of his head and he's also
one of those guys that he yells a lot
you know he walks up to the camera and
for some reason goes
a which is really going to it's going to
be difficult for me to enjoy watching I
don't I just that's the generation gap I
for the life of me I don't [__]
understand that Johnny United threw for
41,000 yards in the 50s and 60s he he
beat out the next guy by like
15,000 [__] yards I don't think
there's any footage of him throwing a
touchdown pass and walking up to a
camera with his flat top
going that's back when you could [__]
hit the quarterback until the end of the
play you can keep hitting the
guy um maybe if he ever did that it was
cuz he was screaming in
pain I was kidding who I'm an old
[__] white guy what do you want for
me I want the game to be the way it used
to be where you established the running
game and then you threw the ball
um but anyways uh
the [__] did I want to talk about there
was something I'm all over the map cuz
I'm stressing cuz I got to finish this
[__] thing and hopefully this
Internet won't suck and I can try and
upload it here um so I figured the next
thing person we're going to play in our
division will be the Dolphins and I
imagine one of them's going to talk [__]
about how uh you
know they don't think the Patriots are
as good as they used to be they're
[__] sick of this they're sick of
that da d da all I know is the Patriots
are on a collision course with the New
York football Giants to be undefeated
and uh I said to verie last night in my
drunken stuper I go can you do me a
favor can you just have the Giants beat
us during the regular season this year
and not in
uh not in [__] uh not in the Super
Bowl I don't know I'm really praying for
the Packers this year to knock off the
[__] Giants cuz I do not want to see
them
again uh I don't I'm good I'm fine with
just losing to them twice I'm I'm good
with that rather than rolling the dice
and risking losing a third time um even
though it would be great to come and
beat him you know and this is why I
don't play professional football because
even as a fan I'm a little [__] girl
I don't want to see them again they
always
win
um but what was I going to say the
uh you know Odell Beckham that they got
and then they got the [__] guy who
does the salsa dance he's coming back
that guy's coming back then they're
going to oh it's going to be a [__]
night nightmare [__]
nightmare um hopefully we get healthy
our offensive line gets healthy but uh
who knows who the [__] knows what's
going to happen but uh anyways let me
get to some of the reads here for this
week um all right who versus
home people always try to explain this
to me and I'll never get you I'll never
get it all right bill I have the
solution to your who versus whom dilemma
that will solve the issue for the rest
of your life okay I hope you're not one
of those snake oil salesmen I feel like
I'm in your tent right now you're
starting a religion you know and you're
[__] putting your hand on my
forehead exercising the demons um if the
statement could be
answer if the statement could answer
answer the question with him or her then
use
whom whom did you say that
to I said it to him I said it to her not
he or she she so it's whom example two
who told you
that he told me that she told me that no
[__] way it's that that's that easy
who told you that she
did whom did you say it to I said it to
him wait a minute so now
using wait so if I to whom do I owe this
pleasure
to you would say am so it is
home who [__] did it he did
it Jesus Christ it was that easy where
the [__] were you 40 years ago when I
needed you maybe I could have passed a
class and got a not to day and become a
lawyer hope that made sense totally made
sense I just hope I can remember it you
know what I'm actually going to take a
picture of that in my phone speaking of
which the phone starts
ringing hang
on
oh [__] hold on hold on hold on
hello I thought I said
11 is is is is Paul and Joe down there
already all right well I'm I'm finishing
up my podcast I'll be down there 11:
sorry about that
okay all right buddy see you a [__] up
thought I said 11:00 that was the bus
driver going just checking we did say
it's [__] hilarious 1010 cuz we've
always been on time so he
knew um so anyways
um God damn it you fixed it you [__] I
got to take a picture of
that whom did you say that to who told
you that that's all I have to
remember I wish there was more [__]
sentences and and then you know you gave
me 10 of them and then I had to try to
guess all right good fellow seene
explained oh my God I feel [__]
smarter you know what the thing about
whom is you can't use it without looking
like a douche the only time you can use
whom is if you write something the funny
thing is if you if you use whom you know
what I mean you sound like those uh you
know and he stepped on the bull those
guys from [__] Trading Places um but
if you're if you're writing it you know
an email or or even tweet something
people will call you out on it because
if you don't use it then then you look
like a douche so I think that's the
other rule you know what I
mean like hey who who'd you say that to
you can't be in a Barbie like hey whom
did you say that
too I said it to him you [__] douche
right you can't do that but you write it
down every you know everybody sees
it you know they just break your balls
so there's another rule all right uh
Good Fellas scene explained okay last
week I thought that the reason why um
Joe pesi in the
end score sayy just brings back uh
Tommy's character and he just points the
gun at the camera and starts shooting
which because that was Tommy from Beyond
the
Grave shooting [__] uh Henry cuz he
was a rat and ratted everybody out um so
somebody said good Fells ex that was my
theory good fellow scene explained hey
Bill you mentioned in your recent
Thursday morning podcast your theory on
why we see Joe pishy Joe pishy Joe pesi
fire a pistol [__] brain is always
three [__] words ahead of my mouth at
the screen at the end of Good Fellas
It's actually an homage or a homage if
you're in a bar uh to the 1906 black and
white film as opposed to the color films
back there The Great Train Robbery it
was was the first film with a narrative
story line and at the end there is a
shot of a cowboy looking at the camera
who fires his pistol at the screen just
like in Good Fellas I actually watch the
clip it's pretty [__] cool it was
very jarring to the film audiences who
had never seen anything like that and in
many cases movie goers would duck or
shout thinking they were actually being
shot at isn't that [__] hilarious
it's cuz everybody had a side iron back
then um just a little film history from
a film nerd to you the funniest red to
you the funniest redhead on the planet
keep up the good work and go [__]
yourself here's the movie all right I
will definitely post that uh that uh
that clip all right election bill you've
been pretty quiet about the election
seems like uh they got their start early
this year and people are going to be
tired out by February if you had to vote
today do you know who you'd vote for uh
also is there anyone less stable looking
than Hillary Clinton she can't be
getting any good sleep love you and your
wife thanks for for the weekly laughs uh
I thought Hillary crushed it on that
stupid
inquiry you know I didn't understand
what the [__] problem was she
admitted that had happened on her watch
and she took full responsibility for it
so like what was the [__]
problem you know that seemed like uh you
know deflate gate type [__] I mean
honestly what what are you supposed to
do to stop a terrorist attack and
they've said that forever like even the
Secret Service said you know if if some
somebody doesn't give a [__] about dying
the only thing that they can sure is
instantaneous death after you do
whatever the [__] you're going to
attempt to do you know what I mean once
you take out the [__] I don't give a
[__] whether I live that there you
know it's over so I mean what what are
you going to do you know was in a away
game it's [__] horrific that it happened
but I you know she should have done this
she should have done that the same
people saying that say George Bush kept
us safe after 9/11 but they don't bring
up the fact that 9/11 happened when he
was [__] president right the same
people breaking [__] Hillary's
ovaries are [__] rubbing George
Bush's balls and then vice versa the
same people finger banging Hillary are
[__] twisting up what's his face is
nuts rather than giving him a pair of
meundies what are you supposed to do
when somebody doesn't give a [__]
you
know what are they going to call you up
and tell you what they're going to
do you know I don't know by the way we
met a uh a professional pilot commercial
pilot by the way
um and uh he knew some of the people on
those flights you know some of the
pilots and that type of [__] so all
these [__] people that are trying to
say that it didn't
happen that they were actually [__]
these missiles or something like that
that was shot shot in there I
mean um I don't know and that's coming
from me who's a [__] conspiracy
theorist all right gangas Khan everybody
hey there
Bilderberg just checking in on you from
[__] southy kid uh I listened to your
podcast almost every day in the sea of
cubicles I work in and you are the
[__] oh thank you I appreciate it I
also saw your comments come
home last year and there were a bunch of
[__] in front of me who were getting
offended at the things you were saying
and it made it funnier for me and my
girlfriend anyways oh I remember that
that one was a little bit of a rough one
you know anyways I just came across Dan
carin's Hardcore History Podcast and the
first one that is free on iTunes is the
wrath of KH series on gangas Khan and
the uh the Mongol Empire during the
Middle Ages this dude was one of the
greatest men and conquerors who ever
lived and his story is incredible the
fear and loyalty this man instilled in
people
of his day is unparalleled although he
is responsible for 20 to 80 million
deaths he completely changed the world
and built the largest Empire the world
had ever seen and I thought you might be
interested in it because you've talked
about other great men who have lived in
the past Arnold Schwarzenegger thanks
for a great show and go [__] yourself
yeah see there's another
one you know you know what it is there's
no
footage on like vlat the [__] impal
and and [__] uh the Gman there
[__] gang as K so you
know nobody got what are you a [__] you
don't get that what are you a Nazi thing
you know I got to check that out I got
to I got to listen to that I got to be
in the mood to listen to a [__]
podcast like I love being on podcasts I
love doing them but
um I just uh my brain is I I can't
handle just sitting still that long I
guess I could have it on in the
background as I was doing something else
maybe cleaning up or freshening up
before a
show um all right my roommate is a
pervert okay here we go uh dude but
let's go back here do you realize the
work it is to kill 20 20 to 80 million
people I mean you can do it today with
just a push of a button but back then I
mean you that's like before they had
like the [__] lawnmowers with the
engines in them and you had to push the
[__] thing yourself do you know I'm
so old that we actually had one of those
when I was a kid it was the [__]
worst and if it was too if the grass was
too
long you just I just didn't have the
strength to do it so you you'd push it
forward and then had to go back you had
to get like a running start you
know that was a mess it was so hard to
keep it [__]
straight that's basically like if you
had like a a a push mower that that
didn't have an edging in it I I would
think that you'd have to like be cutting
it every day like George Michael did
with his beard and then it'd be like
nice and easy right but if you went on
like a bender you know or you went away
to some place that they used to Vacation
back in the day like Sarasota Florida
you know a Myrtle Beach what was some of
the classic ones that they used to go to
way back in the day
Reno you know those old school places
Palm
Springs you know when you came back your
[__] lawn was through the goddamn
well I guess you do it in the winter
time right all I'm saying is that you
were out there all the time that's
probably why a lot of people weren't as
[__] fat although you know what the
big thing was back in the day everybody
was scared about was just having a heart
attack because they couldn't do any of
those [__] I'm going send Rhino
plasty which of course is your nose kids
getting a nose job do you know there's
something called
rhinaria I learned that by ring about
heroin junkies and [__] like
that that uh I something
diarrhea see if I can look it up I know
you guys think I'm full of [__] it's
like diarrhea of the nose it's just
[__] when you uh one of the symptoms
when you're you're quitting cold
turkey Rhino let's see how do you spell
diarrhea d
a d a r r h e a something like that oh
there it is
rhinaria rhinaria rhinaria is a
condition where the nasal cavity is
filled with a significant amount of
mucous fluid the condition commonly
known as a runny nose occurs relatively
frequently rhinorrhea is a common
symptoms of allergies or certain
diseases such as the common cold or hay
fever Oh I thought that that's when you
were uh I thought you I thought you said
you were all right spider um I thought I
can't even say it because I've done it
so many times I always stutter imitating
[__] uh Spider I thought that rinor
Ria was an Next Level runny nose that
you got when you were kicking heroin um
I've kind of got interested in all that
like the whole heroin e epidemic that's
going on here in this country um oh by
the way I keep forgetting to bring up
how great the Indianapolis gig was first
of all I got to come back and play this
theater um you remember that story I
told you guys and I put the video
up where uh I I was playing a theater
upstairs and downstairs was that totally
Elmo show whatever the [__] it was
Keeping Up With The Muppets whatever the
[__] it I don't know what you
know um and when I walked
by the door to the backstage of their
theater was open and like all like the
count was sitting there and Bert was
there and Oscar the Grouch like these
actors in these suits and they were just
chilling out you know and they look
tired from doing a bunch of shows so it
was hilarious so I filmed him and all of
a sudden Bert got up and came walking
over and was waving his hands I thought
he was saying what's up like oh look at
bird hey he's coming up here and he
[__] reached out and slammed the
door and I was just like wait wow he
really is a
[__] but really is the happy go-lucky
one I was joking in Indianapolis that um
that Ernie's Ernie's parents like were
accepting of his homosexuality right
where berts weren't like they kicked him
out of the family so it caused him to be
like sad and bitter you know what I mean
um but thank God he had earned in his
life right cheer him up um anyways and
then I posted the video and then Sesame
Street told me I had to take it down the
children's television Workshop was like
you got to take it down that's that's
not legal footage which I think it was I
mean what I didn't understand what
exactly were they going to do to me if I
didn't take it down I don't know so I
took it down I was like all right
whatever you know what it was was they
were going through that [__] with the
Elmo guy they said you know [__] uh
was grab assing with some kid I have no
[__] clue but anyways so this time
around I got to play downstairs where
the Elmo theater was and uh it's one of
the great theaters I've ever played in
my life as far as the crowd was just on
top of you they had like those those
little balcony things they had like four
of them on each
side it was like an old hockey arena it
was just [__]
awesome uh just been an incredible
incredible [__]
um incredible [__] uh tour here and
we went to one of the sickest [__]
cigar bars I've ever been to which of
course because I was [__] an idiot I
just walked into it I got to look it up
right
now
Indianapolis cigar bars all right let's
see let's
see
blend this [__]
place might have been the greatest Cigar
Bar I've ever been to it's [__]
incredible you have to go to it and and
they're opening one in Nashville and
Dallas all right just six selection of
[__] cigars they had the davidof uh
davidof uh
Nicaraguan um all these other just
amazing cigars that's the one that I
smoked and then they had the like all
these whiskies limited edition wh
whiskies and Bourbons that um that I
thought I I mean did you know they they
had they had Jack Daniels Sinatra I'd
never even heard of that me and Bart
we're like what the [__] is that like
that was his drink I'm like he just
saying Syra cuz that was his drink
they're like no that's a a limited
edition
um I'm looking it up right now Jack
Daniels
Sinatra where is it
here yeah I never I never [__] heard
of this [__] and of course they were
sold out of
it let me do the old Wiki here Wikipedia
Jack Daniel
Sinatra Wiki
I well did you mean that of course I
meant that you know what I
meant ah God damn it all was doing show
Sinatra select that's what it was called
anyways it was [__] just an amazing
amazing place and uh don't you hate
these [__] websites when you go there
and you got to [__] put in your
birthday all right I'll give you my
birthday we'll say uh
November 11th
enter please enter a valid year they
don't think it let's see let's see what
year they'll actually let 1893 they
won't let let's see when they believe
in 1890 how about 1899 do they they
don't believe anybody's alive how about
1900 see that's what it is anything with
an 18 go [__] yourself
enter Sinatra select bottle of 90 proof
and made with unique Sinatra
barrels it sounds like [__] [__]
to me Jack Daniel Sinatra what is that
Sinatra Barrel it's it got a [__] T
pay on it sorry select pays uh tribute
to Jack's biggest fan Mr Frank Sinatra
These Sinatra Barrels have deep grooves
on the inside of their staves which
exposes the whiskey to extra layers of
Oak ah God damn it now I got to get a
bottle
but you can't just get a bottle they got
a video here of Frank Sinatra pouring it
I wonder if his [__] next to
Kin gets any
money dude they got a picture here
sitting at the bar of Sinatra laughing
while Jackie Gleason's laughing with
them Frank Sinatra and Jackie gleon were
close friends in fact it was Jack Jackie
gleon himself who introduced Frank to
Jack Daniels and as the story is told it
was sometime in the 1940s Jackie and
Frank were sitting together at a bar in
New York City Frank was for loone over a
woman he probably wrote a great song
about it and was sharing his troubles
with gleon Frank informed his good
friend that he was in need of of a
serious drink turning to Sinatra gleon
responded Jack Daniels that's a good
place to start and the rest as they say
it was history oh Frank said he needed a
drink well there you go all right what
the [__] am I talking about at this
point all right let's get back to the
podcast um
so definitely check out Blendon if you
live in
um if you live in
uh Nashville or Dallas they're on their
way over there all right let's read a
couple of [__] advertising and I'll
get the last [__] thing in there and
I'm out all right all right lastly but
certainly not
leastly um all right my roommate my
roommate is a perv so sir bam of
Boston I'm a longtime listener love your
[__] anyway my roommate just started
dating a girl a lady and they're getting
uh really couply they even talk about
having sex with each other in front of
people including myself I have a
girlfriend but I try not to be overly
couply or discuss our sex life in public
uh the worst part is that they have
taken to having sex throughout our
shared house including our living room
couch and our kitchen I think that their
behavior is annoying at best and
disgusting at worst but I'm certain but
I'm uncertain as how I should proceed do
you have any thoughts also go [__] go
[__] thyself yeah I have some thoughts
why don't you sit them down and say hey
can you guys do me a favor and not [__]
on the
sofa all right this isn't your house
this is our house I don't need your
bodily fluids all crusted up you know on
the
couch I would just
dude I I would just you know they like
openly talking about sex just say listen
you have sex in your bedroom don't have
sex on the couch where we all sit it's
gross I would say that and I would just
and I would just stare at them until
they
talked I just I go I just is there a
reason why you guys feel it's okay to
have sex all around the house I live
here
too you know I make a sandwich on that
kitchen counter I don't need to know
that her ass and dripping [__] were
[__] laying on there you [__] pig
you guys are both animals I have no
respect for either one of you all right
go ahead and
Advocate it'll be a [__] who no you
don't going to be that mean just be like
listen I'm not trying to be a jerk I
think it's great that you found somebody
that you can connected with but could
you not have sex on the kitchen counter
please or in the kitchen I eat in there
it's
gross see that sofa over there I sit
there and I watch TV all right I I I
don't need that see that table I eat
there
all right if you want to [__] all over
an apartment you're going to need to get
your own apartment but until you do this
is our apartment and
don't [__]
anywhere where it's you know where it's
ours I feel like I could use who or whom
here maybe you should bust out a whom
see if I can do it here all right whom
whom did I say that
to I said it to
him yeah that's what you say you come
out of the gate using whom to freak him
out call call you the guy be like can I
ask you can I ask you a question he be
like sure uh whom did you [__] on that
counter he's got to be like
her or my
girlfriend what if he says my
girlfriend you got to say that I would
just be like whom did you [__] on the
counter who whom did you [__] on the
table and whom did you [__] on the
couch that almost sounds like Bill Cosby
and why with a
children ah you can't bring up Bill
Cosby especially when you're talking
about a woman right it was consensual
everybody all right that's the podcast
for this week I'll check in on you on
Thursday and once again thanks to
everybody that came out in Indianapolis
Cleveland Detroit and
Pittsburgh um just four [__] great
cities Man Four great cities and it's
great to see uh all of them are having a
Resurgence every time I've gone back
they always get a little bit better and
I think it's great because like I said I
I love this part of the country I'm not
going to lie to I like all the parts of
country you know I'm a patriotic when it
comes down to it so it always made me
sad to come to Cleveland and Detroit and
Indianapolis and that Cincinnati and
that [__] at 5:00 where everybody just
screws and goes out to the suburbs and
the [__] place looks like a zombie
movie at night uh it's nice to see some
nlife and that type of [__] cuz they're
beautiful cities all right there you go
legalize weed open the plants again
let's grow some weed let's get the world
high right and maybe they'll give us the
oil for the price we want we don't have
to blow people up you know what I
mean all right go [__] yourselves I'll
talk to you on
Thursday what's up everybody and welcome
back to the anything better podcast NFL
Edition sponsored by none other than b
MGM guys we are going into week eight
but first we got to shout out the great
sponsor B MGM love the lines love bmgm
baby we're rolling with the lion Bill
bmgm all you guys got to do is download
the B MGM app to bet with us uh put as
little as $10 in your first deposit and
you will get up to $200 in bets
regardless of the outcome regardless
wage
all right all you got to do is use our
code which is bur2 200 bu
rr200 okay you download the app you use
that code put in as little as 10 bucks
you get $200 uh regardless of the
outcome bet responsibly they also have
the uh Survivor pool still going you go
on you pick a team to win not against
the spread just a team to win and as
long as you win you go on the next week
and you do the same thing that team gets
eliminated so on and so forth there you
go we're here for uh week number eight
and uh yeah man I was happy I was happy
to get above 500 for the first time it
only took me this long but I went three
in one um mean know he took you this
long you do this every year Paul I told
you Paul verie in
October Vegas is running in the other
Paul you always start slow yeah and then
in October you beat the [__] out of him
I want to see your lifetime record in
October you're a monster you're a
monster in October um you're like the
month of March Paul you know you come in
like a lamb you go out like a
lion well you are you are still in the I
went one and three last week Paul I was
0 and3 going into Monday Night Football
and had the Vikings and I was like I
think I'm going 0 and four I think I
lost my shoulder too where the hell did
it go dude um you like my new highi I
got over there when you said I actually
like that room uh when you said I swear
to God I do I keep my bunker in New
Hampshire keep I keep looking at that
stone fireplace I'm like that thing is
killer um dude when you told me I was in
Vegas when you told me that you were you
the only thing you were hanging your hat
on was the Vikings and oh I'm not gonna
lie Paulie I was in Vegas and I had a
couple of wines I had a couple of Reds
and I was in Vegas so I threw some money
on the Niners did a little tease got
hurt what are you gonna do you know
couple hundo what are you GNA do yeah no
dude I would agree with you if I could
have switched that bet I would have
switched to the 49ers last night cuz I
obviously didn't know [__] about
anything last week but uh the Pats won I
didn't see anything dude I was at a uh I
was at a wedding last
week uh dude Patriots last second M
Jones touchdown I did not see that
coming dude that was a great pass how
about the Buffalo Bills Paul four and
three four and three Dolphins five- two
the Jets they're only a game ahead of
the Jets they're a game behind the
Dolphins hey Bill how about they lost to
the Dolphins they've lost to the
Patriots the only other person need to
lose to in the division is the Jets this
was Paul this Paul this was a for gone
conclusion at the beginning of at
Midsummer before uh [__] Aaron Rogers
went to the Jets was that they were they
were gonna they're just gonna wal to the
AFC Championship Game Paul they're gonna
go up against these Kansas City Chiefs
they're finally gonna put it to I don't
even know if they're gonna get out of
the AFC East yeah dude how about the New
York football Giants defense the last
eight quarters only giving up three
scores dude they are they had six and a
half sacks our defensive line turned it
on man and and I I'm loving it and we
have how about your Giants getting
disrespected by being underdogs against
the [__] Jets I know I know speaking
now who who like I don't understand how
that works like as far as a home game or
whatever that like if it's it's the
Giants home game the majority of the
people get the
opportunity yeah the Giants home game
means the season ticket holders for the
Giants get first crack yeah all right so
there's my question on a scale of 1 to
10 how much
better just as far as like if you're
hanging out with the human being is a
Giants fan better than a Jets
fan you know somebody it's a funny
question it's a good question because
somebody said why are jets games like so
like more lively during plays and
there's more of a desperation with them
like I I like giant fans are like all
right dude let's do it come on guys
let's do it it's not what it is F not
what it is ignorance is loud Paul the
Jets crowd is dumber they are louder the
Giants fans are smarter they have money
they have something to lose you look at
the Jets fans I mean you can just see
those broken down picket fences in front
of their
houses yeah there's a desperation there
it's so funny yes those are people that
work with their hands the Giants fans
you're the PE you hire Jets fans to come
over and redo your [__]
driveways you guys drink wine look
you're in Vegas Paul you drinking wine I
mean who the [__] are you who are you
Paul to have the goddamn nerve to go to
Las Vegas and drink wine like you're
some sort of Aristocrat oh dude I had a
sweet I'm not gonna lie I did a
corporate I was in a suite in the H
Venetian oh dude I order you want to
laugh I get back to the room at 2
o'clock in the morning I was gambling
dude bu myself blackjack tables roulette
I even went to penny slots I had a
tequila in my hand I was enjoying myself
I was there for a day right and uh I go
to my room and I got this monster sweet
Bill like I mean I wish I could have
shared it with somebody I was like and I
Paul enough about the hookers let's
let's stay on topic here I call up room
service and dude I got shrimp cocktails
delivered to my room with a chicken case
of D at like two in the morning and it
was everything the guy came in in a
[__] Butler gown and [__] was [__]
unbelievable what's funny about you Paul
you sound like a Jets
fan no you go I got shrimp cocktails I'm
like how many did he order well no I
ordered one and the guy came with extra
and I was like all right I just ate all
this [__] at two in the morning I was so
full I just what do you mean he came
with ex when does a shrimp cocktail
become shrimp cocktails I know all of a
sudden I no I'm asking you no I don't
know I got I got two plates of it and I
oh dude I only ordered one oh I see okay
so you got shrimp cocktails so yeah so
like multiple orders of shrimp cocktail
come okay I always just hear casad a
chick shrimp cocktail never shrimp
cocktails shrimp cocktail there was six
of them times two I'm eating 12 it's two
of them I'm stuffed but I'm eating them
it was hilarious you split Aces
crustations I did I got beat on the
blackjack table um but today is the day
that I have first pick is that
right yeah I'm interested in those
sunglasses Paul let's go put those let
me see those on let me see
those oh I don't know Paul you don't
look like the good guy in the movie all
of a
sudden oh speaking of movie
congratulations nightstalker crushing it
old dad is crushing it I'm not allowed
to promote that Paul because of the
strike oh okay well there's a movie out
there it's doing well ah let's get into
the picks there you go here we go here
we go oh they call me f uh paully first
pick this week and here's what I'm doing
this one was a no-brainer dude they call
you Mr October that's what they should
call you
um well pa versy three and one two weeks
in a row the man is six and two no no no
no three and one the last three
weeks three you've gone three1 three
weeks in a row yes sir and we're in the
what fourth week of October yep I am I'm
153 and Paul ver win it in October dude
you're nine and [__] three nine and
three in October
um and and hopefully with this pick I
I'll continue it I've seen my New York
football Giants play better defense the
last two weeks than I've seen him in the
last three seasons I have not seen a
Giants defense like this a Relentless
pass rush um and I think that tay Banks
our uh rookie cornerback is really
really coming around he's been locking
down some of the best receivers in the
game the Giants are disrespected at home
they are plus three now it went to plus
three which is in my
favor uh I'm going to take the New York
Giants they're clicking I think they got
[__] by Buffalo I think the Giants
should be three and four and I like what
the defense is doing I got the New York
football Giants at home playing the team
that rents the building with them uh I
got the Giants plus I like that pick I
don't like when you did
it you could have saved that pick till
last now maybe I'll take one of your
games
you know you know I'm staying away from
the Giants Paul you know I got too much
love and respect for you I would never
touch that game but listen I don't know
the rest of my pigs spill because I'm
all over the place oh okay I I okay your
little little little uh little seat
filler there all right I'm a little
Wishy you with the pics this I'm not
gonna lie to you everything looks good
to me and everything looks bad okay I'm
gonna go uh I'm gonna take the Texans
minus three going into Carolina
Carolina's 0 and3 0 and six sorry I just
don't see them uh they're just I don't
know what they're doing but they're not
doing anything good the Texans got a
good enough defense I don't know [__]
about them either but uh you know I'm
sort of paying attention so I'm going to
go with the Texans minus three going
into Carolina gonna get a little vinegar
get face barbecue Saturday night and
they're gonna [__] on him on [__]
Sunday dude that's a great pick that's
such a great pick that's a lot you know
Paul you said that last week and I went
one and three okay so you know let's
relax here
what was the one I said though was I the
one was it the winner you like the
Chargers but you love the Chargers Paul
the Char you know what the charges are
Paul the charges are like your first
love that not even the first [__] hot
chick you nailed that's who it is like
you weren't going to marry her no but oh
Paul you'll remember you'll remember
those times for the rest do you remember
I don't know what it is with the
Chargers of me all right um for my
second pick here going for week eight
H I'm not gonna lie to you dude I don't
love any of this but um come on Paul
it's
October just make
contact speaking which did you watch
either one of those game [__]
sevens uh dude I couldn't believe the
Diamondbacks won that game oh man and
that kid he pitched out of a couple of
jams I gotta be honest with you I love
the Phillies they reminded me of the 04
Red Sox they just everybody had like a
douchy face with a big beard and and
everybody hated him I mean that one guy
I always forget his name I always want
to say Josh broland what's the [__]
guy's name there on the Phillies he's
doing everything stealing bases hitting
doubles singles [__] whatever you
want Bryce Harper no yeah oh I mean that
guy is he's like that guy in the 80s
movie The Coming of Age he's the guy
dating the cheerleader treating her like
[__] and then I show up with my glasses
and I go oh you dropped this and then he
beats the [__] out of me and then the
end without lifting any weights or
taking any classes in a dojo I somehow
beat him in a fight and and start
banging his girl that that was an 80s
movie it was it was considered
believable believe it or not hey hey
Bill remember that guy I sent you from
the Phillies dude the guy with the one
tooth he goes game seven tomorrow night
let's go Philly D he had like one eye
one way I'll be honest with you I don't
buy I don't buy this the the Philly fan
propaganda I've gone to games I don't
see people like that I see some animals
it's kind of like Trump followers
like liberals just go to the middle of
nowhere and they just find the dumbest F
out there think the [__] world's flat
Donald Trump I don't care if he [__] my
sister and they're like oh my God these
Trump people dude there's a lot of
[__] smart people in
Philly yes I love it I had a great time
Somebody's gotta [__] keep polishing
that BT all right just stop with the
it's like the [__] you go to a Bills
game everybody's not [__] jumping on
a table some people have
lives
all right speaking of that here's what
I'm gonna do I just hit me it just hit
me I'm gonna take the points I'm gonna
take the points I'm gonna take the for
for the first time this year I'm gonna
take the Tampa Bay Buccaneers getting
eight and a half against the Buffalo
Bills who are clearly broken the Buffalo
Bills are broken everybody something is
not
working something's not work I'll tell
you right now Paul uh nothing scares me
in this
world
like the [__] NFC
South I know I I mean I've just bet one
of those games I don't know what the
[__] they're doing I you tell me week to
week what the Falcons Jets Buccaneers
and Panthers are doing well Panthers are
[__] in the bed that's what they're do
panthers are [__] in their own crate
Paul dude you said it you said it best
when I see I say a lot of things
Tennessee Titans I just get scared any
game the Tennessee Titans are in it's
like it's like uh poly Kryptonite I
don't they were money last year they
were money last year this year I don't
know all right speaking of that Paul I'm
actually going to take the
Titans oh I like the Titans they're at
home they get they're getting three oh
but the Falcons got that [__] alien
at running back yeah bejon does he go
running does he run wild this week Paul
does he run wild like your wife with a
credit card in a mall did they even do
that on Amazon is that what they do it
now yeah she just run on Amazon she runs
wild on it um what I saw I liked it oh
Jake The Snake coming in see AR Jonah
Hill coming in Titans will have a backup
quarterback I don't like thank you Jake
The Snake you know at least somebody's
doing some research here all right I'm
just going right here now Paul look at
this look at this I'm doing a little
dance here I'm going with my gut I'm
going with my gut here
uh I'm GNA leave that game because I
don't think you're G to [__] with it I'm
going to
take the
I'm gonna take the Kansas City Chiefs
laying
seven at the
Broncos no no uh they're at home I just
think the Broncos
uh I don't know Paul I don't know what's
going on with them but I I just feel
like feel like the Chiefs this is
usually when they start hitting their
stride Paul Paul I haven't watched
football in two weeks I'm not gonna lie
I don't have any reasons you know what I
like the Chiefs uniform they're pretty
they're laying seven they're at home
Travis Kelsey Broncos are home
Broncos one home oh I [__] that one oh I
still don't care yeah seven the points
still seven listen Paul I'm a broken man
I'm just gonna go with the
Chiefs okay I'm just throwing punches in
the dark over here I I haven't watched
the last two weeks oh Bill I'm already
watching hockey I'm watching my Boston
Bruins I'm
um you
know I don't I don't know what's up
what's down right now bill you got the
look on your face like me and you are
having a good 45 five minute
conversation on the phone after
this oh and you know what Paul it's not
going to go anywhere it's not going to
go it's just going to be me venting to
you there's no solution H there is no
solution there is no solution it's still
nice to talk to a friend I'm here you
know what the solution is Paul your
garage guess what I did today in the
garage I lifted weights for an hour and
then played drums for an hour like I was
still [__] 18 I feel great oh that's
nice you know what I did I ordered a
dumpster I ordered a dumpster from a
company and I put it in my [__]
driveway and uh do you know how many
comedians names I just wanted to say and
then so and so showed up at your
house and uh dude we just unloaded I'm
cleaning out the garage you remember my
garage my garage my house could be
Immaculate my garage looks like PE dude
I just let me ask you what then what are
they doing with the once you put it in
the
dumpster then whenever it's ready and we
have all the stuff the the stuff it's
it's a Rubbish Company it's hilarious
but to throw at the ocean why's trying
and sell it they come no no this is
stuff you can't sell this is like broken
metal this is like this is like stuff
that can't be oh broken metal from your
karate days okay that's right Paul has
back when Paul had hair he used to do
karate chop demonstration videos
[Music]
yeah first four years I knew Paulie was
in his bare feet like that's how
committed he was to the martial
arts so wait Bill uh Andrew is asking me
you're you're pick you're changing your
pick you're not doing the Titans correct
you are doing the Chiefs I might do the
Titans later on Paul okay you know what
I mean all right like that waitress you
have an eye on down at the diner you
know that might happen a little bit
later down the road if things go south
right I mean diner diner [__] you you
don't go to a titty bar those chicks are
crazy that's true you Paul you the next
one you want a woman that's used to
bringing you
breakfast then you know what you do then
you know what you do you marry a
waitress Paul yeah you fall in love with
her and then you show up to the diner
and you look at her you confess your
love to her and you go this is your last
shift I'm getting you out of here you're
coming with me all right and then what
you do is you remodel your house where
it looks like a diner so she feels
comfortable then you hire a chef and you
get one of those little bells ding ding
ding and you scream at where's my
[__]
coffee no you don't want to do that Lo
the diner PA all right oh my Diner oh my
Diner all right for my third pick for my
third pick this week all right so I got
two dogs rare for me I got two dogs
Paulie's taking points this
week that's what I've been doing too
yeah for my third pick I mean they're a
bad this is a bad
team
um you don't want to hang out with these
guys I think that the commanders are bad
oh you
[__] I love that pick I'm gonna
take the Eagles and I think they already
had their good game against the Eagles I
thought you were gonna stay away from
that that's a great pick Paul jersey you
[__] I was going to but I'm
going I'm watching them and the Eagles
aren't playing really great either and
the commanders just don't have it and I
think their their coaches on the hot
seat I'm gonna take the Eagles as my
first favorite this week minus six and a
half in Washington I thought the
commanders were having a better season
than people thought and I o think that
they had you know if they were going to
beat the Eagles it was the last time it
was like that game was like
3531 all right um I love that pick you
[__] [__] well then you know
what I'm taking the Titans getting
three in Music City hey by the way
everybody in Nashville stop saying
everybody from La is moving to Nashville
they aren't everybody that moved to LA
and then couldn't afford it are now
moving people who who are from Los
Angeles are staying here they don't give
a [__] about Nashville all of those
people that say this from La ask them
where they are from
initially thank you
sorry yo you're like you're tight the
Titans to you are like the Chargers to
me you just love them dude you can't you
love a Titans team hey Paul I love my
mother and I love the Titans and they
can do no wrong I love Mike Rabel oh
dude uh I know the Titans have a backup
quarterback so I think all the Jake the
snakes are going to be like hey you
should probably go with the fal I
haven't bet the Falcons all year
though the Falcons have won for me man
that that kid is they're always in every
game all right so I got Paul everybody
has a different relationship you know
the Falcons lost last
week uh the Falcons won they won last
week all right they'll lose this week
all right I'm gonna stick with the
Titans Paul Remember the
Titans great movie great performance by
Denzel
favorite I I mine it's a great porno too
sorry he go like this he goes he goes he
was talking [__] he was going hard like
in the movie it was almost like you know
just like running up and he just goes
I'm a winner I'm going to win and he
said it arrogantly and I was like that's
the oh I love it all right for my fourth
and final pick I want to see
Denzel play a beaten down
man he did and Man on Fire
was that the airplane one no no that was
because I love the airplane one where he
was struggling with alcohol yeah just to
see him do something because I know he
can Crush those [__] like the guy
just dude when that guy when was the
last time that guy didn't hit one into
the seats in a movie now he gets all of
it he gets all of it no I gotta be
honest with you as far as like that
guy's been making movies since like
87 yeah Glory he's been killing for 35
five [__] years yeah and every actor
has like oh you know the you know
they'll they'll make a choice and
somehow it doesn't he doesn't have
that he just doesn't have that no he's
just he's literally one of the most
consistent every well I'm waiting for
him to played that role because he's of
that age he's still in great shape but
he's of the age where you know you you
do a little salt and pepper thing there
and uh like I love when when when
Pacino was in Donnie Brasco and he had
that [__] frumpy coat and he didn't
have good instincts and everything it
was just fun to see yeah a beaten up
kind of a like a goofball yeah yeah um
I'm calling it dude he's gonna do that
he's gonna get an even another Oscar
they don't give it to Merl
stre
uh what does she have on Hollywood Paul
I swear to God she sneezes in a movie
she gets a [__] Blockbuster award
nobody sneezed like that nobody sneezes
like Merl Streep I don't know what to do
for my fourth and final pick here I'm
really really confused but here's what
I'm gonna do you what you do Paul you
put your balls on the table I'm gonna
take the Cleveland [__]
Browns against the Seahawks against
Sneaky Pete getting three and a half
wait did that line change is the Shawn
Watson coming back no nope but what
happen him Cleveland won the last two
games with this backup Walker kid so and
the line only changed a half a point
because of
desan uh guys is the is the line is this
the line
here three and a
half Jake The Snake there he is Jake
Jake did you get your class picture
today I mean what is that [__] shirt
you're wearing I haven't had that shirt
since like the third
grade I got a laugh A J I thought it was
stylish no it is sty you look great dude
you got you got your whole life ahead of
you don't listen to some old bald orange
person oh thank you what do we got Jake
um still at three and a half all right
I'm gonna I'm every week Cleveland is I
keep looking going wow Cleveland's good
wow Cleveland wins wow Cleveland's in
the game and I haven't really taken
Cleveland so you know what I'm gonna
take them getting three and a half I
love the half a point I think the half a
point could be the the deciding factor
for the win here and um I just don't oh
I see what you're doing what you were
like that hot chick just standing in the
wings waiting till they were making
enough money and now you coming in like
hey Cleveland what are you doing going
to Seattle this weekend big boy I see
with you little Paulie little Paulie
[__] uh little opportunist can I tell
you something every time I go against
Sneaky Pete he bites me dude every
[__] time I go against them they I
like Sneaky Pete against a backup
quarterback oh I know and every time you
say that I get bit but you know what I
gotta beat Sneaky Pete once and I hope
this is the week I can do you got to
walk away you know I walked away from
I'm done for the season is the
Pittsburgh Steelers I don't know who
they are dude they don't know who they
are those bipolar [__] if I
take them they get crushed if I bet
against them they show up dude Mike
Tomlin I mean I'm starting to take it
personal all right oh God I have two
[__] games Paul that have just
[__] bite me in the ass right now I
know which one of I know what one of
them is what is that you got to be
looking at your Patriots getting nine
and a half I mean that's got to be one
of
them we already beat the Dolphins that's
what I don't like and and Bill bur oh no
we didn't beat the Dolphins we should
have beat the Dolphins bill you told me
when me and you first became friends
many moons ago you go a division rival I
don't give a [__] and you guys are
getting a lot of
points there has to be a reason why it's
nine and a half when we beat the bills
last week I'm sure there's some sort of
[__] injury something's going on or
somebody just came back Tyreek Hill's
cousin has just been activated or some
[__] something something's going on down
there Tyre I just like to watch the
Patriots and and you know I just you
know let me just watch them I'm gonna H
Paul you make a good point though I'm
looking at the
49ers wow laying five and a half and I'm
looking at the Ravens laying eight and a
half in Phoenix he's a big [__]
numbers Paul bill you walk into the fire
I mean you walk you're a fireman I mean
look at me Paul I I look like Marshall
Bill I mean it's it's what I do I mean
why I'm here Bill looks at a tough game
and takes it just you're just running
into the fire the [__] Ravens the
Ravens haven't even let up a 100 points
yet this year the Cardinals have a
backup quarterback the Ravens have are
just more talented at every
level Kyler Murray's at a steak and
shake
right he's gonna get fat I I don't know
people know that I have a I have a I
have a bet with Paul one of these
Seasons he's gonna come overweight he
just it's something about his face he's
in shape but his face still looks like
he's eating Donuts yeah I know what you
mean I think he's young in shape I don't
buy that that he's in shape I'm just
stalling here Paul ah what do you have
to bring up the
Patriots [__] that I'm not doing
it because last week they showed up I'm
not doing it I'm just gonna watch the
[__] game and everybody can [__] up
um I'm going to I hate the 49ers I don't
know they they they don't cover they win
but they don't cover [__] this I'm
taking the Ravens eight and a half in
Arizona I just [__] myself God damn
it all right I'm taking the [__] he's
going he's going that's it I I I you
know Paul I I don't want to talk about
it okay you know I'm embarrassed by my
behavior and I I will try and work on
that in the future does that make you
feel
better um I'm gonna go on YouTube and
figure out how to rering these things I
don't know who the was that decided that
these magnet [__] things to pull down
your curtain that's why I'm all out of
out of phase here aside from the fact
that I don't have any
pigment um all right so I think that
those are our uh those are our picks
there Paul before we do the Monday Night
Football game we have to do a segment
that I've been wanting to do for a long
time I tweeted about it is you know
we're a couple of bald guys right we're
a couple of guys just hanging out in our
basements doing a podcast uh you know we
Hair Envy yeah so we have we have this
new segment called uh first ballot hair
Hall of Fame and these are people that
you see on
TV that that just they have the same
hair that they had when they were like
in the fifth grade and uh the first
nominee that I have you do you have one
in your
head uh I think so all right I'll let
you go first because I was prepared for
this who do you put in in your hair Hall
of Fame that that that covers football
or just like is it has to be yeah
wherever the [__] you want to go Paul
who do you
got but like you just look at him as a
bald man going do you do you understand
like how [__] insane it
is it's like dude it's like a
fairway I I'll go first I'll go first
[__] Teddy brusi you could lose a
golf ball and the hair he still has on
top of his [__] hair you're sitting
there with the [__] club going where
is it where is it Teddy brusi I thought
you were going to go Jimmy Johnson I
thought that was your guy uh Jimmy
Johnson's another one I I'll name
dude Jimmy Johnson Man Jimmy Jimmy
Johnson is actually more impressive
because he like usually if you make it
through your 50s you know I don't know
even then every once in a while you you
R your 70s you can start to [__] lose
it and this guy is in his 70s I believe
and my God Paul what about what's his I
mean he could play Santa Claus if he
[__] grew it out and got a beard I
mean he's just gorgeous it is it's and
it's still shiny it and it looks soft I
mean it looks he got that rich guy
conditioner you know like most old guys
with white hair it starts turning yellow
and you see their Broken Dreams and
their long fingernails not Jimmy Johnson
Jimmy Johnson is is like that he's like
he's garaged you know like that car you
love dude can can I talk about I got to
talk about something real quick okay
Bill I tried to avoid this topic I got
uncomfortable when you texted me about
it but go ahead dude it just was it just
was a bad visual no dude it was I was in
Vegas and I wanted to go to the steam
room and they said well do you want a
massage because the Steam and the sauna
come with that and I'm like I'm all
right and then they say to me would you
like some champagne or mimosa and then I
go yeah I got happy so then they handed
me a [__] champagne and she they go
why don't you you wanted have you ever
got a pedicure
and I was like no so they were like just
get a [__] pedicure dude so dude they
did not say let's get a [__] pedicure
they said would you like a pedicure yeah
and I was like yeah and I had champagne
and I go in with this lady she's been
doing it like 40 don't blame the alcohol
Paul you wanted to get your toes painted
it's fine it's 2023 nobody judges any no
they don't paint your toe they don't
paint your toes they you know they put a
clear thing on it Paul there a
paintbrush your toes are there and
that's what they're painting here's what
said she goes wow you got really nice
feet and I was like thank you you know
because they're you know they're tan and
[__] yeah Jes dude they dunk your feet
in this hot tub for a while and then you
just soak it like in like a massage
water and then they basically give you a
massage they polish it they make sure
the nails are dude it was it was insane
man then they put this like hard rub on
the on your ankle it was awesome my feet
were brand new when I was done and I was
like dude I'm doing this [__] I'm doing
this [__] dude the rest of my life I'm
getting petties yeah I'm in I'm in
listen I'm sure your wife is
thrilled I mean guys feet I mean they
usually look like you know you've been
[__] dragging it down the street with
your car door open actually the woman
said the opposite the woman who's been
doing it like 40 years she was really
nice she said her husband's 69 and
everybody says he's Michael Jordan
because he looks exactly like him and he
signs he's like he goes I'm not Michael
Jordan and she goes he just like he's in
his 60s so that doesn't even add up but
he's just like gets tired of it but she
was amazing and you know what she said
she says women's feet are way worse she
says the ratio of men's feet being
better she goes the reason why women's
feet are worse is because they [__]
cram their feet into shoes that don't
fit to lift their butt to lift their
legs they're they're all [__]
scrunched up in those heels where she
goes men want more Comfort men wear the
right socks the right sneakers women
just put their Sho foot in a [__]
thing and they're uncomfortable all
night and it [__] their feet up I
thought that was hey Paul jacking my ass
up got me a free house I'd do it
too
what's
it I put on a pair of pumps to not have
to work women do have that option uh
that's that's true uh you know what time
it is right oh well who who was your who
was your nominee
though we'll do one a week we'll do one
a we'll do one a week we go let's go
Jimmy Johnson cause he's older Teddy
brusi almost made
it so again next week Jimmy Johnson all
right first ballot air hall of fame
Andrew you gotta keep you got to keep a
list of these all right and there it is
everybody
sorry uh oh I know what a time for let
the Monday night
special wait a minute for you did we win
the Monday night special last week
special no how do you know
cause uh they didn't cover or it was
Minnesota one
no no no no no no dude oh that's right
that's right we had it straight up we
had a money line yeah yeah we had a
money
line no we had Kurt Cousins throwing one
which happened we had mcaffrey getting
one which happened and we had them on
Paul if two out of three one you
something on Monday night we would kill
it if if the Niners money line hits okay
well you know what we're gonna get him
this week Bill I'm sorry like this is
like the Bears losing streak here like
what the [__] are we doing
by the way let's quit [__] around
here and make some people some [__]
money the lions are coming off an
embarrassing beating from the Ravens the
Ravens [__] skunked them last week
and they're not
happy they
are eight and a half Point
favorites who against the Raiders now
why why is it eight and a half is Jimmy
G
playing um I think he is playing is
Jimmy G playing J come on let's ask the
doctor here is he playing I'm not I'm
not sure um but I can look it up but um
not sure at the moment they took him off
the field I think he had an injury but I
think he could be questionable he could
be a game time whatever but dude the
lions are gonna win this game at home
after a beating like that that they're
gonna win it at home but I mean the
Raiders got like ridiculous wide
receivers they have three glorious
targets they got a great defense they
that [__] lunatic on defense who's
that guy that white dude Max Max Crosby
is oh my God I love that
guy that guy plays the game the way when
I grew up that's how it was [__]
played I mean he he if you put that guy
on the Raiders in the 70s he doesn't
look like he time traveled he looks like
oh I'm finally in the decade I should be
in I [__] love that guy hey how about
this let's get can we do this Andrew can
we get Max Crosby one sack for for this
week I think we should take the Raiders
should be fine
I think we should take the [__]
Raiders eight and a half [__] points
I think they got a great D I don't think
the lions are as good as everybody says
they are I think maybe they'll win I
don't think they're going to cover I
like the Lions Max I mean I like the
Raiders I like Max Crosby getting a
[__] sack and I'd like to get a hair
transplant you know I mean that's that's
what I like for Monday
night Jared gof to throw
one Jared Goff to throw one I like that
that kid's an animal this year let's do
that let's do Jared G to throw One Max
Crosby to get a sack and do you want to
just take the lions with a money line
Max Crosby to get a sack is a pretty big
[__] I mean they're gonna be keying
on what what's what's what's their old
line look like over
there um it's good they have a good
offensive line but that kid's
unbelievable man that kid like our
intelligence before we went to Iraq it's
damn good that kid that kid will get a
there that kid will get get a um [__]
this all right let's just Paul whatever
okay we've gotten this far let's do dude
let's do Li let's do lions money line
forget let's get these people a win what
wait what what is the money line you
just gotta pick a win gota win a game I
I look I don't know who's gonna win this
[__] game to be honest with you all
right if you I like I like the Raiders
getting eight and a half let's go Max
Crosby gets a [__]
sack uh somebody dresses up like [__]
Darth Vader's Brother In The
Crowd Oh can we do that can we do a
little there's going to be a a Darth
Vader you know a lot of Raider fans are
complaining they don't like Vegas
because it it doesn't feel like a home
game no I know it's because everybody
goes to I mean that's that's great for
the franchise because they're gonna sell
out every game but they were selling out
anyway yeah um right all right so we'll
do that then uh we'll do Monday night
special Max Crosby to get a sack Jared
gof to throw a touchdown and we are
gonna take eight and a half points with
the uh with the
Raiders looks good yeah I don't like
that over under [__] that I would take
the under I would take the [__] under
all day 45 and a half I take the
under
that do that instead of what the the
points the eight and a
half no I like that okay the one I was
questioning was Max Crosby getting a
sack you don't think you get in there I
think he's gonna get like two or three
that's why I don't like it it just seems
so [__]
easy in case we can't build it that way
you want to do an alternate one well
we'll swap out the max Crosby and just
add in the under yeah let's take the
under so Raiders the under G to throw
one if Max Crosby if we can't build it
that way I like how we're taking Raiders
we're betting on the other guy to throw
a touchdown while while taking the under
sometimes they don't even let you build
them like
that well see what he says it's sayy
listen it's our show we make the rules
we're above 500 now they they'll do it
if they can I think we're at 500 with my
three losses this week my apologies I'm
at 500 we're two we're two
above are you two games above 500 no I'm
15 and 13 yes are you in the eighth
grade what
movie oh [__] damn it I don't midnight
run midnight run all right oh why didn't
I put on my sunglasses because I left
them at the
wedding oh man hey Paul it
happens you know you go to a wedding it
[__] happens all right I got to get
out of here because uh I got [__] uh
I got to do my Thursday [__] here
all right all right well this has been
uh preview for week number eight for the
NFL for the anything better podcast
sponsored by bmgm guys all you do is you
bet a minimum of $10 you get 200
regardless of the outcome of the first
bet regardless Freddy stto yep uh use
bonus code rest of Soul use bonus code
burr2 200 bu
rr200 okay you do the Survivor pool okay
which we have uh pick a game every week
team gets eliminated you keep going and
uh there you have it bet responsibly 10
bucks get you 200 everybody enjoy the
week let's go Raiders